anyways okay let's continue let's go to
the buccaneers antonio brown obtained
alleged fake covet 19
vaccine card from teammates page eight
uh so he plays for the box okay if you
don't know who this guy is antonio brown
is uh at one point i think he was the
fastest guy in the nfl
on thursday tampa bay times
report claimed that tampa bay buccaneer
star wide receiver and tony brown used a
fake cover 19 vaccination card to get
around certain nfl health and safety
protocols without having to receive one
of the safe and available coronavirus
vaccines i like the way they said that
one of the safe and available chrono
vaccine shots the nfl and its reviewers
uh uh the matter but the overall
situation took a different turn friday
when espn's gina lane reported ruiz says
brown obtained the alleged fake
vaccination card from a buccaneer's
teammate he got them from another player
who was selling them
rui said that player came over to the
house multiple times he had to get
another a copy of brown's girlfriend's
vaccine card because they got her
birthday wrong on the first one faking
or doctoring a covenant vaccination card
is a federal criminal offense and also
violates the nfl's personal conduct
policy meaning brown could be fined or
suspended if the league proves of this
uh ultimately believes ruiz's claims
gerard thoughts listen you take somebody
that's completely and totally healthy
and tell them that they can't work
unless they inject themselves with
something that they don't want to inject
themselves you're going to create a
black market all right this is this is
after this is right on the heels of
aaron rodgers all right where they tried
to skewer aaron rodgers for for his
decision why does the elite media why
does the the let's just call it what it
is why why when i was in in st louis all
right
i posted all about it if people follow
me i posted all about it on and i went
on this whole rant about every place was
closed shut down all right place was hit
hit hard by covid and it was shut down
and the places that weren't shut down
all right there was one place called
gramophone it's like the only place that
was open and in order to get in for me
to get dinner all right it's a sandwich
and beer shop i had to show a negative
coved test within the last 72 hours or a
vax car to go inside and eat a sandwich
and i'm out there and the guy the
bouncer who's sitting outside with a
mask on outside i'm like bro
i'm going to go inside and i'm going to
have a sandwich no one's sitting in
there no one's around me
you need me to prove
just this i was like what if i have
herpes i'm going to drink out of this
glass and then somebody else is going to
drink out of the glass that i'm going to
drink out of shouldn't i show a negative
test from that
the old herpes
should have not shouldn't you guys prove
to me shouldn't i be able to see that
you guys are cleaning things effectively
does this so anyway i get into this
whole thing with this guy obviously
because you know i had to make a scene
about it i'm just sitting here like wait
a minute man
every place is closed every place is
closed here's one guy trying to give you
business and you're saying no
no you you can't come in because
you're not
obeying us has nothing to do with health
what do you think is going to happen to
antonio brom that's what what do you
think's going on
he's going to get suspended and fine
well i think so because the nfl needs to
make an example of somebody there's
going to be a fall guy just like there's
a drug test he's an easy guy to do it
too by the way yeah and if you think
about it antonio brown is an easy guy
it's not like it's mahomes or it's brady
you can do it to this guy they didn't
suspend rogers so they i don't think
they can suspend antonio brown
rogers said what roger said he had taken
a vaccine
but he didn't go so far as the fake
passport yeah that's the differentiator
just so you know guys i've gotten
arrested for having a fake vaccination
card just so you know that so can you
google uh a arrested fake vaccination
card i remember a father and a son asian
picture came about like six months ago
where these guys got arrested for having
a fake vaccination card illinois woman
arrested over a modern vaccine card yeah
new york man charged with felony for
faking vaccine card yeah this is this is
not like it's a uh
seven year in prison oh hang on go back
to it go back to it watch this new york
man charged with felony could face seven
years in prison after being accused of
faking a coveted 19th vaccine this
pisses me off
what i'm what i'm trying to say to you
is what i'm trying to say to you
your answer is what they should do to
him that's not my question my question
is what do you think the nfl goedel will
be forced to do to brown he's the if
phil's going to cave and again they got
to make a fall guy because they got to
set up like a set of precedence for the
rest of the league just like they do the
drug policy you pop test for a banned
substance and that kid whoever is
playing is gone for the year
i think that's going to happen to eb
he's been in and out of the news teams
for a handful of years now i'm more
concerned about his quote unquote
teammate who was selling them as a side
hustle
what kind of guy out there is that on
the teammate be like look you went on
fake like
focus on playing blocking and tackling
you you don't think that's happening all
over the audience
that has a fake vax card yeah this
person had covet didn't want he's
healthy didn't want to get the vacs
travels sometimes internationally
has a fake vax card and this is not
a right winger to say the least he just
wants to be able to do his thing so
you brought up the word black market and
that's exactly what's going on here
anytime that there's rules and
regulations that you don't agree with
you're going to try to skirt the issues
it's just crazy and that's what's going
on here it's just crazy as a felony it
just that pisses me off because you have
a felony on your record you can't get a
job but you can get licensed not think
about this think about this okay
can you sue them where's accountability
lie right now can you sue them if they
get sick if you get sick can you sue
them of course not you can't no and fi
the the fda who's supposed to be working
on our behalf
just
asked a federal court
to withhold the the the fo the foi
all we've been told is trust the science
trust the science but you can't read the
science until
2075. you know she has made it also a uh
you know illegal so where's
accountability accountability is shut up
and do what you're told shut up and do
what you're told by the way
gerard said that so quickly can you pull
up that story
because uh that's uh
you're coming out with a product that we
cannot sue here you go this is the this
is the story a vaccine vaccine is an
injury attorney fd asked judge to grant
it until your
let me read this guys fda asks judge to
grant it until year 2076 to release
pfizer vaccine data
attorney sri published an update on his
case against the fda and he wrote the
fda has asked a federal judge to make
the public wait until the year 2076 to
disclose all of the data information it
relied upon to license pfizer covet 19
vaccine this is not a typo it wants 55
years to produce this information to the
public so let's get this straight the
federal government shields pfizer from
liability gives it billions of dollars
makes americans take its product but
won't let you see the data supporting
this product safety and efficiency why
does the government who does the
government work for so this is a very
big problem huge to have something like
this setting up for themselves yeah 2076
that's what 50
55 years from now insane to be able to
do that so will anything happen to him
will anything happen antonio brown
yes
well he didn't play last night on moneta
football i don't know if he's injured
right now or if he's suspended currently
but he didn't play last night on monday
night football i don't know if it was
with the ramifications do you think the
nfl is going to go as far as suspending
him from the season
no okay do you think this is going to be
like a one game or two gamer type of
suspension okay what do you think's
gonna happen to the guy that's slanging
him if they can do an investigation that
guy's gotta have to answer some serious
questions okay so you think how many
other people did he sell them to sure
what kind of side hustle is he operating
let me let me ask you this question let
me ask you slippery slope here what they
do if the nfl finds out
and this guy comes out and says i'm
selling a vaccination card says just so
you know there's 30 other guys that's
selling it on every single team not on
my team
on every team
because if a guy selling it on tampa bay
who's the poster child of the nfl
he's the captain of that team which
means you don't think tom knew this so
tom knows this so i think
i mean we can't assume that he listens
no if you've read tv 12 also if it's
odds if we're playing the game of odds
odds are a captain's gonna know that
this is taking place if this is taking
place roger goodell is probably gonna
want the story to go away and not make a
bigger deal about it because he knows a
brady in the super bowl gets more
eyeballs than a you know somebody else
in the super bowl so let's just address
the elephant in a room too if aaron
rodgers didn't get suspended and antonio
brown does every black person in america
skip and shannon is going to go nuts for
an entire week he didn't lie about
having a vaccine card though
it's it
wait wait are we are we talking about
nuance and facts mattering all of a
sudden like
it was immunized yes
i mean
half the world still thinks kyle
rittenhouse killed three black guys so
there's you know he's a white
supremacist come on man yeah yeah i mean
you know we live in a world where when
uh that that that poor bastard drove
through not the the crazy bastard drove
through
yeah
drove through wisconsin half the people
were waiting to see whether the driver
was white or black to see how to respond
this is just the reality of the
situation now it's not right it disgusts
me to the core of my freaking being i
hate everything about this so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]